at University of Florida researchers
they were working on basically an
unrelated project and they discovered
that they can collect human DNA in the
air they were just studying sea turtles
and they noticed that they were
collecting a lot of human DNA because
quote we cough spit shed and flush our
DNA into all of these places and
countless more and then you just pick it
up it means that you don't need to worry
so much if you sent in your DNA spit
sample to one of those ancestry websites
and then check listen if they want to
clone you they're going to clone you you
don't you don't need to send them a spit
sample to do that we are not just
hurtling toward our dystopian future we
are there